is there anything that you like that he
won't do Harry
um
no he's he's he's DTF he's the guy
that'll like your [ __ ] like he's
you're down for it all I yeah how long
you guys been married 35 seven four
it'll be 14 years 14 years oh yeah
almost 14 years but together together
17. yeah we met his kids basically I
know newbies open bikers
yeah no it's so crazy yeah you guys have
got a good thing I know I mean I listen
to you guys sometimes and it's one of
those things you guys are able to talk
like you don't know each other you are
you're able to ask like you just asked
him what are you what are you what do
you like or what are you afraid of you
just asked your husband of 14 years what
he's afraid
that's so true yeah that's the thing
about you guys yeah yeah I was listening
to One where you were talking about
school and about yours failures in
school and you're asking them really and
you're like just still discovering each
other yeah but that's real love that's
real love yeah you think so oh yeah
yeah it's it's still this far in and
you're still interested and curious you
could still the tool you'd be in a go to
a party and you'll be in a corner
talking to each other right yeah because
I think when you stop being curious is
when it's the death now right maybe
you're just like well there's Dependable
also and there's all those things but
curious is important and people